okay so there should be a pretty quick
video here kind of the basics of
microscope drawings you know what's
expected and maybe some of the errors
that we can try to avoid along the way
so let's get started okay so here's our
microscope and we're gonna select to get
started the lowest magnification
possible the lowest power objective lens
and we'll look through the eyepiece of
course and when we do we're gonna see a
round view this is what's called our
field of view it's the view that you can
actually see when you're examining the
specimen now pretend we're looking at
these cells right here these were cells
taken from an onion skin an onion peel
well now we have some needs to address
so the first need I want to address is a
title tell the viewer of your drawing
your observation what the specimen is
what are you actually looking at the
next would be what is the total
magnification of the microscope remember
science is repeatable and if you have a
really interesting observation that you
are sharing the only way you're going to
be able to repeat it is if you address
what the total magnification of the
microscope is well then we have to do
our drawing an accurate depiction an
accurate drawing of what you're able to
see and then finally we can add some
labels some identifying characteristics
to help point out what it is we are
observing well let's get ready to do our
drawing here's our blank field of view
that we're gonna assume draw in and our
first decision is should we use a pen or
a pencil now this should be an easy
answer I hope we're gonna do a drawing
there is a high probability of making a
mistake
let's go ahead and select the pencil
it's cleaner if you do make a mistake it
erases better so we're gonna use a
pencil now the first thing is let's
select the title how about microscope
drawing after all we're making a
microscope drawing I hope you realize
it's too vague
maybe cells cells for a title after all
these ourselves again too vague be
specific tell the viewer what it is
you're looking at cells taken from an
onion peel
okay so next I'm gonna focus on the
magnification now earlier I said we're
gonna select the microscope for the
lowest power possible so there we go
low power well I hope you see the
problem low powers not specific tell the
viewer of your drawing what is the
actual microscope set for and in this
case pretend the lowest power was a
hundred times magnification
now that might vary depending on your
microscope you are using don't assume
that every microscope in the world has a
low power of 100 so be specific and tell
the viewer what the magnification is and
now we can you know start to focus on
the drawing now let's say prior to doing
the activity that you're doing in class
let's say you were reading through your
book and you saw a real nice diagram of
a plant cell maybe an animal cell
side-by-side for comparison and then
when you look through the microscope
should we just start to draw from our
memory all these beautiful cells that we
saw in our textbook well one of the
things I hope you'll get from this video
is no draw an accurate representation of
what you're actually seeing and so when
I look at this picture right here an
accurate representation of this picture
I'm gonna begin with my pencil and I'm
gonna do my drawing here and notice I
only filled about half the view what
about this other half well notice how
the half that I completed looks pretty
much like the half they did not complete
so because the entire field of view that
fits this pattern here I'm okay you
don't need to fill in the entire field
of view as long as you know what you did
fill in is a fair representation so we
can go ahead and just kind of leave it
like this now let's just focus on the
drawing you know from this picture I can
tell that there are really three parts
I'm gonna have to label you know one
being the cytoplasm you know cells have
an interior fluid filled space called
the cytoplasm and these are eukaryotic
plant cells taken from an onion so
there's their nucleus and
cuz these are plant cells I know the
outer boundary is the cell wall so I've
gone ahead and I've labeled neatly the
characteristics that I'm able to
identify you know let's take a moment to
focus on some errors that I've seen over
the years what if I label the cell wall
like this with an arrow well the error
would be to use the arrow straight lines
touching the cell part and the reason is
look what the arrow head it's actually
touching the cytoplasm but it's pointing
towards the line so there's a little bit
of confusion what am I actually
identifying with the arrow we can fix
that by using a straight line that's
actually touching the cell part you are
identifying another common error would
be to do this labeling the nucleus
inside of the field of view the labels
really should be on the outside for a
very simple reason whatever you include
inside of your field of view you are
claiming you can actually see underneath
the microscope you can't actually see
the word nucleus typed underneath the
microscope so a straight line touching
the nucleus off to the side of the field
of view and how about this label and the
cytoplasm like this well I hope you see
that the common mistake here would be
the criss crossing of the lines it gets
a little messy if you have to label four
or five six seven different parts when
you have you know multiple lines Criss
crossing one another so a nice straight
line to the center of the of the object
you are identifying in the cytoplasm
now I've already labeled the nucleus but
I can still show you another common
error I've seen over the years again one
of the things that I want you to focus
on is horizontal lines and horizontal
labels if you have to label four or five
six seven things and they're all written
like this it gets really sloppy and
really confusing so a nice straight line
with a nice horizontal label and and
there you have a good drawing
now remember we said earlier our
microscope was at the low power which in
this example was a hundred times
magnification let's zoom on into a
higher magnification so right now I just
have it labeled high but let's say we've
zoomed in our microscope to the highest
power possible on your particular
microscope well now we have to do
another drawing again a fair
representation of what we're seeing we
said earlier these are cells from an
onion peel no reason to change the title
now the difference being is the
magnification in this picture let's say
that this was a magnification of 400 X
400 times stronger than what the human
eye is able to see naturally well now we
have to do our drawing and so when we do
our drawing we're trying to do a fair
representation of what we're seeing and
hopefully this looks okay to you now if
I focus on labels I can start by you
know labeling horizontal lines touching
the actual part the cell wall maybe next
I can identify the cytoplasm
maybe next I can identify a nucleus now
notice inside of some of the nuclei
there's a darker spot inside the nucleus
that would be the nucleolus so with a
higher power you can see more detail
often which means there's more parts to
identify and here we have another
example of a microscope drawing so as I
wrap up this video I want to point out
one other common error that I've seen
over the years here we have a hundred
magnification onion skin cell peel on
the left and a 400 magnification of the
same specimen on the right when we do
our drawing try to draw a fair accurate
representation as we've said before same
thing with the the picture on the right
try to draw a fair accurate
representation and notice this is the
common error I've seen from time to time
is the cells virtually look identical
even though the picture on the right was
magnified 400 times in the picture on
the left only 100 so this has to be a
mistake here because again the cells
magnified
400 should appear much larger if I do a
fair representation of what I'm actually
seeing maybe it comes out looking like
this and I can clearly see more detail
on the picture to the right than the
picture to the left so try to focus on
drawing an accurate representation of
what you're seeing so I hope you found
this video helpful and thank you for
watching